you know the old saying everything
happens for a reason
that reason is usually physics
i'm bill nye you may know me as the
science guy yes i use science to solve
problems and make things
when you think scientifically that
enables you to attack virtually any
problem i don't want everybody to become
a full-time scientist the fashion
consequences of that alone would be very
troubling
but we do want everybody to have a
fundamental knowledge of science and
appreciation of critical thinking
this class is a shift in perspective
i'll show you some ideas that i've come
up with over the last 40 years stuff
i've never discussed on any television
show a way of thinking a way of
accomplishing goals a way to not be
fooled
it's very easy to think something is a
reliable source when it might not be ask
yourself is the claim specific is there
a simpler explanation and can it be
independently verified
we've all felt fear fear comes from the
amygdala our brain gets hijacked affects
your ability to think logically if you
like to worry about things you're living
at a great time and if you're like me
you're very concerned about climate
change there are more fires they're more
floods the world's warmer than ever but
with our scientific understanding we can
take that fear and turn it into
excitement we're going to talk about the
solutions and how design will help us
all address big problems turning nerd
ideas into nerd action
and that my friends is the essence of
science the joy of discovery you learn
more about yourself and your
relationship to the world around you we
need big ideas and those are going to
come from you and me just think what is
possible in the next few decades it
fills me with optimism about the future
let us think critically to save the
world
i'm bill nye and this
is masterclass
[Music]
you